hello how are you doing i just saw you
personally i know
hi how are you doing i'm kevin how are
you tara how are you doing
guys just make sure to share this yes
we're going to put y'all right there
ready yes sir this is these are pretty
crazy times for you because you could
win a grammy tonight
you could also be oscar nominated very
very soon um there's the super bowl what
has this
been like what is this like you're
taking over the world
man am i wow i mean it feels crazy i'm
so blessed
because you know we had such a tough
year and the fact that i can still do
what i love and give people hope through
music and
just do me and reach these higher
heights it feels crazy and i'm
excited um huge news that george floyd's
family got that settlement but it still
doesn't bring him
back and that's why this song is so
important
um what will it be like to perform that
song
what would it be like to perform i can't
breathe um you know performing it would
be
amazing yeah if i could perform it but
um it's
it's powerful yeah you know when we
wrote it we were on facetime and it was
it came from such a tough conversation
you on facetime
yes wait how did you write the song over
facetime
it was it was conversation we were just
talking and literally everything that we
said were the lyrics
yeah it was really in the midst of
everything that was going on we were
right in the midst of everything that
was going on and she called me and she's
like
hey you know we start talking and would
you you had your you're at your mom's
house yeah i was at my mom's house in
her bedroom in her mom's house
and yeah we just wrote this song on
facebook yeah i had my guitar
and it just it just happened because
that's how powerful
that time was so many people playing
that song in the streets you hear it
over and over again
how important is that i mean it's been
the soundtrack to a movement
yes you know one of many songs and i'm
just happy to be a part of history now
um all right so now let's talk about
black messiah and
yes what has that movie experience been
like and tell me about writing that song
man for us it's been a learning
experience
um the thing about it is you know the
fred hampton story is not taught in
schools
at all and that's very sad you know so
we literally had a little history
lesson and writing the song just kind of
connected that time and now and the fact
that we're still in that struggle we're
still in that fight
was it interesting or what was it like
watching the movie because the song
fit so perfectly to the time you felt it
you felt that
feel the panthers the movement
everything how did you get that
feel it was right after we got done
watching the movie yeah
when we started we watched the movie in
the studio yeah we did it was like a
movie night in the studio
yeah and then we were listening to like
marvin gaye and curtis mayfield yeah
and that's my favorite era anyways so
the fact that we got to tap into it it
was
it was kind of easy and then when we got
to the message it was like okay
everybody's fighting for something we're
all trying to fight for our people for
love for
all of these things and that's kind of
how we got to this this groove and we
wanted a hopeful
you know we did we didn't want it to be
sad we wanted to feel hopeful
in this moment is this kind of the
moment where you're like really sky's
the limit i mean
honestly grammy oscar i mean
what's next what's next man right i'm
i'm sleeping girl whatever god has
planned you know
um the fact that i'm doing what i love
is what it is and i'm just to keep going
and
keep keep living and walking through my
purpose and i think that's going to take
me further than anything
there i'm sure are there some young
women out there who are sitting in the
room and they're playing a guitar or
they're playing a keyboard
what would you say to them what would i
say i would say
do you and always walk in your purpose
and lead with passion because yeah keep
going
it'll get you further you know just
doing you and by the way is it
how is it that you know when you're
writing these words that are so
important you know they're so important
and they mean more than just a song that
people
sing on the radio that this will touch
people's hearts but it's also part of a
movement
what's going through your mind knowing
how important these songs are especially
on a day like today where
a year removed from brianna taylor yeah
well i feel like it's something that a
message that we need to speak about you
know as artists i feel like that's an
artist's job to speak about either
whether it's going on in your personal
life or what's going on in the world so
i think we just really wanted to reflect
that what was going on and so it is a
really good feeling for
you know to be able to write something
that other people can
have experienced the same thing you've
experienced because everyone's
experiencing
this together you know the fight that
we've been in i think people have gotten
away from like
writing really powerful music so thank
you all for doing this it was too much
like cars and thing
and other stuff and this is this is
important we were missing
i think the substance in 2020 really
showed us that we needed
something that meant something greater
than
us and it brought us together i think
music does yeah
you're giving us hope okay thank you
you